[Music]
well welcome to another episode of the
addie hour it's my pleasure to welcome
you all back and i'm really honored
today to host what i think is a really
timely conversation especially as we're
getting ready on several college
campuses and university campuses across
the nation to go back to our fall
semester obviously this is a fall
semester that again is different from
what we've experienced before and so i
think today's conversation is very
timely as we think about campus life as
we think about mental health and faith
in our ongoing pandemic world and i'm
grateful for the guests who are joining
me today
these individuals i've known for a few
years and have been able to interact
with and partner with in different ways
and so i'm excited to be able to share
their words with all of you and i'm
really looking forward to our
conversation and the wisdom that i know
they're going to share with all of us as
well
so the first guest i'd like to introduce
is chaplain sharon coogler
and sharon has been the chaplain at yale
university since 2007.
she came to new haven from johns hopkins
university in baltimore where she had
served as university chaplain since 2000
or since 1993.
she has three decades of experience in
ministry in higher education and
interfaith collaboration and in pastoral
pastoral and social ministry her main
focus at yale has been cultivating
chaplaincy for students faculty and
staff which defines itself by serving
the needs of the richly diverse
religious and spiritual traditions on
campus allowing for deeper dialogue
increased accessibility personal growth
creative educational opportunities and
pastoral leadership and sharon is also
one who has served in several different
leadership roles in national chaplaincy
organizations so i'm grateful and
honored to welcome sharon coogler to the
addie hour podcast today thanks so much
for being here
it's my pleasure it really is
the second guest i would like to
introduce is orlando yarborough iii
orlando is a scientist certified
leadership coach consultant speaker and
trainer he coaches and trains a diverse
international portfolio of young
professionals academics and community
and business leaders in leader
development professional and
communication skills and personal growth
he also pastors the black church at yale
also known as bk which is a student-run
church on yale's campus that has been in
existence since 1972.
dr orlando
orlando is a meyerhoff scholar who holds
a ba in biology and african studies from
the university of maryland baltimore
county and a phd in genetics from yale
university
he also holds certificates in marriage
counseling and pastoral leadership and
is certified as a maxwell disc method
behavioral consultant and maxwell
parenting and family guide so deeply
honored to welcome orlando yarbrough to
the addie hour podcast as well thanks
for being here orlando
thank you it's my honor to be here
the third guest which i'd like to
introduce is omar bajwa who is the
director of muslim life in the
chaplain's office at yale and who has
been engaged in religious service and
inter-religious engagement and
educational outreach since 2000. he
holds degrees and has a certificate in
islamic chaplaincy he also has an m.a in
near eastern studies and an ms in
communications
he's someone who has studied several
classical islamic sciences with
traditional scholars from pakistan
turkey and the united states his
interests include islam in the united
states and the intersections of culture
media politics and spirituality he
regularly lectures about these topics
and others around the country and he is
also the co-editor of a forthcoming book
mantle of mercy islamic chaplaincy in
north america so thank you omar for also
being here and joining us on the adiaba
podcast today thank you to uh profound
privilege thank you
well again i'm grateful to all of you
for being here and i just have to start
by saying how grateful i am for the work
that you all do on campus and you know
investing in students and really walking
with them in their spiritual journeys
and especially with all the topics that
we're going to be talking about today
obviously that's always important work
and even so much more so and all the
things that we're experiencing as a
society these days as well um and even
before we start i think you know we're
going to be talking about important
topics but also just want to of course
acknowledge that there are challenges
that are going on all over the world
sometimes things that get more pressed
than other times obviously the events in
afghanistan but just acknowledging that
these
challenges are things are going on an
ongoing basis and want to be just
acknowledging and and constant of that
even as we're having a conversation
today too but knowing that this is in
the context of that as well i'm just
want to make sure that you know our
audiences knows that we're thinking
about those things as well and just the
um the challenges and sufferings a lot
of people are going through in many ways
at the same time it also gives me hope
just being here on the screen on the
airwaves with all of you and knowing
that we're all in this fight and this
struggle and this joy of life together
so with that just wanted to start out as
i often do just checking in with all of
you to see how you're doing these days
this is obviously again another unique
semester that we're entering into on our
college campuses and just want to see
how you all are doing overall both in
your personal lives and in your roles
and interactions with students um so
sharon if we could start with you
sure thank you
uh i think you know i want to first say
i i ended last semester as exhausted as
i think i'd ever been
in my professional career just uh what's
the expression tired to the bone
and
so the month of july i i took a
technology break um and that was very
helpful to step away from the email
i'm still doing some work but just
really putting a pause on zoom and all
those things because i was frankly
nervous
about the next year about this this
new semester that starts in just two
weeks and um
it did help it made it made a difference
and it gave me a chance to have
um
some meditative time
and i've been doing a lot of thinking
about what our students have experienced
how they're trying to make sense of what
they're coming back to
the anxiety levels are very high
everywhere
but especially with young adults uh it's
we know this the studies have shown the
increase in in this challenges
so i
am also aware that i can't uh
i can't fix it all it's not my role
to fix it all but i can witness it
and tell the truth and that's what i'm
trying to do we had a
staff retreat last week a day-long
retreat together omar was there and
part of the theme of the retreat was
there's healing in the return
and so we're talking about that that's
the words of uh the buddhist teacher
sharon salzberg and
and what does it mean to return
and what does it mean to be part of that
healing so that's kind of where my head
and my heart is right now
uh as we look to the fall
well thanks for your honesty and i
appreciate you sharing that reflection
time as well and the ways that you are
identifying with your students and
understanding what they're going through
what we're all going through i'm curious
if it was difficult to pull away
even at the beginning even as you had
said that in motion was that how did
that process come about
well you know you really have to give
yourself permission to do it
because honestly it's muscle memory
i mean i i don't sleep with my phone on
the bed table i that is one flight of
stairs away
and that's been a good habit that i've
kept
uh really i've kept that up ever since
i've had a smartphone um
and
uh it it's made a difference so that i i
don't have that reflex when i wake up in
the morning uh but it's the first thing
i pick up when i go down scared you know
so i had to really pay attention to that
and and also ask myself the question
when i'm opening my computer what is it
that you're doing
are you writing something great
are you reading something that's been
written and isn't sort of a social media
thing
awesome
so i but it took i would say it took
probably four days to establish
discipline yeah yeah i think that's
helpful to hear as well i mean even as
you're describing
the phone being a flight of stairs away
i'm sure many people kind of recoil oh
just kind of that that wow can it can
the phone really be that far away what
if i missed something important so i
think you're exactly right and it sounds
like in a way you've uh
you set up a discipline
but even with that it sounds like it
still took time so i think that's that's
really important that you were able to i
think that's a good principle too
because i know you know with students
that i've interact with that's been
something we've talked about a lot just
giving yourself that time the intensity
is to day one say oh i couldn't do it it
didn't work and then to get stuck and
then
start to beat oneself up and kind of get
stuck in the cycle so i appreciate your
your your candor and that too and you
know taking us through that process as
well so
what about you orlando how has the how
has the uh
process been for you in terms of
everything that we've experienced and as
you're you know getting ready for the
fall semester
yes thank you um at the beginning of
august i got a chance to take a
technology break and spend time with
family um in a different state and that
was refreshing um it wasn't planned so i
don't necessarily take plan technology
breaks though i should
but this was one by circumstance and it
just helped me to be in the moment to be
present
and to
um
say okay i'm away
and i can connect uh in a different way
with people i think as i enter this
semester in terms of my role
as pastor bk i'm warned and we haven't
even started
and i think i'm born in terms of
strategy
i don't necessarily know that there's an
expectation for leadership to have
answers
but certainly the time where you need a
leader is during the time when there's a
lot of uncertainty and i'm just
recognizing that i can't plan that far
ahead
uh and or
yes can't plan that far ahead um
maybe not even a couple of weeks ahead
and
i don't have all the answers and so the
question is
you know what are the values or what are
the principles what are the spiritual
practices or even the the goals that i
may want to hold on to and may want to
encourage our members and our students
to hold to
so i think in terms of being a strategic
leader i'm warned
because i'm not coming up with
long-term strategy and i think that's
appropriate for me not to do so we've
seen that long-term planning doesn't
stay
and
at the same time
i am hopeful and challenged about the
idea of having spiritual community
on campus or spiritual community that's
connected with the academic
start of the year
if there's any time to
bring a wholeness to who
i am to who our communities are
this is the time to do it so i think
my being a part of this work and being a
part of the larger fabric of yale
university and off-campus ministry
um
we're made for this time
and so that that gives me a lot of hope
and encouragement and i'm looking
forward to
just being the person for this hour and
connecting with other people as students
who are the people for this hour
that's really encouraging to hear and i
appreciate your level of transparency as
well um and i think i'm sure this has
likely been your experience but i know
for me that level of transparency is
healing in a sense too as our students
know that we don't have all the answers
as they hear us walking through it as
well and as they see us also leaning on
each other and on them
as community members and as you talked
about the spiritual community i think
that goes such a long way
and eddie glaude jr was on the podcast
previously a couple weeks ago and one
thing that he talked about which you
reminded me about was just the the
wholeness that can come from brokenness
as well
because you talked about the wholeness
of community but not to say that there
aren't cracks in the jar so to speak as
he mentioned and so even as you are
trying to figure out what the strategies
look like you haven't figured it all out
but you're able to lean on community and
to have a sense of wholeness with the
community in that space and i think
that's really powerful i would i would
imagine that your your students get
strength from that as well as they see
you walk through that journey so i
appreciate you sharing that yes thank
you
omar what about what about for you
that's you yo thank you too
my friends and colleagues just fantastic
answers i think for me there's been sort
of this juxtaposition or this tension
almost between you know two overriding
uh feelings one is you know to be very
honest amongst friends you know in many
ways i felt myself really in the last
year and a half able to breathe right
with just the force slow down right the
nature of our work in the academy in
these spaces in academic spaces and
community spaces is that we're always on
and i just felt like for me very
personally i spent a lot more quality
time with my family i was able to to uh
revisit a lot of my spiritual
disciplines and practices that i'd
always that i had that you know sort of
that wayne what you want to get back
into and so and then
of the of the blessings i would say of
that is i had time where the outside
world was shut off and then i got to do
writing which i'd always wanted to do
when i sat down with my friends and we
worked on this book project together um
which is forthcoming as you mentioned
thank you uh and so that in that way i
feel incredibly grateful and blessed uh
to the almighty for everything that i
got at the same time you know i'm
mindful of the world has been and
continues to be a place of deep sorrow
and tension and and and brokenness as
you know we've witnessed you know so
many levels um
but at a personal level right now too is
i am full of as as orlando said too the
uncertainty of the fall semester like
i'm just finding myself day after day
we're getting closer to the opening of
the semester and i just have this this
this this unease and anxiety with like
you know
like the the unknown like what's it
gonna be like you know and i understand
things keep changing we have to be
nimble uh we have to be flexible with
this but but uh i mean what i think a
year ago where i was feeling it was very
different place
um so but thank you for asking
well that's encouraging to hear as well
just a refreshment and as you've named
just the tension that's still there as
well i'm also curious if you talked
about some of the spiritual disciplines
and the writing you've been able to do
even amidst the anxiety that you're
feeling as we all come back to campus in
a sense
how do you anticipate those moving
forward do you think those disciplines
will stick are you starting to are you
going to see how it goes you have
it sounds like you have the space to
create them and is that space going to
still be there as you go forward because
i imagine that's something that a lot of
students will be thinking about as well
yeah i know thank you i mean you that's
a million dollar question that i ask
myself every day right is that i want to
there's days when i think i've got this
i can do this i can maintain it you know
one should be healthy once you be
balanced how they do it there's other
days where i'm just like oh no
something's got to get jettisoned over
the edge right of the ship to keep it
upright
so
i think i can go back and forth day
after day
but i'd like to think you know i'm
surrounded by by incredibly supportive
people that one of the things that that
i've sort of tried to remind myself
throughout this is that you know no man
is an island right so to speak i can't
do it alone like all of the support that
i've had uh has come from family friends
colleagues that has allowed me to to to
flourish in my own way so and i'm going
to be mindful of that and so it's just
about shifting we're going to re-engage
with community right with our friends
with our colleagues with our students
and so it's about re-navigating that yep
right
yeah yeah i really appreciate that and
it reminds me of what sharon mentioned
too in this topic that you only talked
about in the return
coming back and the returning and i'm
curious if if any of you are willing to
share some of if there are any
principles that have come out of those
discussions even the retreat that you
all had together in terms of ways to
return or maybe things to try and be
aware of um along any of these aspects
in terms of spiritual practices in terms
of mental health just in terms of
navigation um so anyone is willing to
kind of share some of the maybe some of
the conversations around that
you know i think um
omar and orlando both touched upon this
in different ways but they're we're
living with contradictions right so
so there there's the built-in kind of
anxiety and and worry that we feel of
the unknown
um and we've been living with the
unknown for so long now
that sometimes
the word doesn't even have the power
that
we know it actually has but we just sort
of glide over it there's so much unknown
well that means there's so much loss
there's you know there there's so much
uncertainty these are all big heavy
things
um at the same time there are also these
joys that are there dancing in the
middle of a two you know we're seeing
each other again
we're
planning for a kind of you know a future
we're not sure what it's going to look
like but
we're trying to put our heads together
and figure out how can we pull off this
ritual
you know how can we do this or that and
that that that
i think is feeding us um but i think
what came out of our retreat and
certainly omar please um chime in
was also just a willingness to say
there's just a lot of mess ahead
and we have to be kind to ourselves and
each other as we sort of tromp through
it
and that's just us the adults so you can
imagine how students are going to be
and they live a life that is a lot
faster paced you know i was
just talking with a friend the other day
about
students on their phones are having
probably five or six different kinds of
conversations with different individuals
in their lives all at the same time
they could be texting with a family
member they could be texting with the
professor with two friends with somebody
they want to be friends with and then
they're also filming themselves and
they're doing all kinds of other things
and so there's just there's a different
energy that students have as they work
walk through the world that we as
chaplains and and imams and ministers
are are witnessing
and
trying to help them also step back and
and kind of gain an agency over
themselves and so i think about the
beginning of the school year
and normally
our offices would be crowded with
students coming by to say hello and get
an ice cream and all those things
and now we're going to be there but
we're going to be masks and they can't
loiter and
you know so it's all
it's all going to be a kind of messy
albeit loving
something and we just don't quite know
what it'll be but you know what i'm what
i'm most
excited about is providing some kind of
soft landing for these students that are
processing so much both in their
personal lives but also in their
academic
and social lives so
well that was really well said and even
though it was probably not meant as a
profound word even the way you just said
it will be something
i think that that captures it
all the different pieces and all the
elements we don't know what all that
will look like but it will still be
something and that something will still
be meaningful
yeah if i may just one more thing i
think that and i appreciate you catching
that as a leader
you know i'm often asked questions that
i just don't have answers to and i feel
horrible about it
um but i do know there will be something
it's so true
yeah
or anything you want to add there from
you yeah no thank you sharon uh uh
fantastic you know we're very little to
add i mean i think one of the thoughts
that i was that i keep coming back to
and
we talked about the retreat as well
is you know
and i'm guilty of this as well right the
language of when are we gonna return to
normal when will things go back to
normal like normal classes normal social
interactions and all of that and and
look just as much as the next person
like i'm i'm pining for that right but i
think uh you know one of the things that
i remind myself is you know to just
really
shift the lens in a sense that say
well of the many lessons that maybe the
pandemic and this the global slowdown
has taught us is that you know what was
normal before and normal may have worked
for some but it didn't work for many
right in terms of race relations in
terms of health care in terms of
education in terms of predatory
economies
and the list goes on and on right and so
i i mean i don't have the answer except
to say that like
is that the normal i want to go back to
or is there or can we can we try to
create a different normal or world right
um that's something that you know this
idea of healing in return is we're being
invited back to
to return to a semblance of life
together uh and how do we heal right the
fractures uh from as the last years
taught us right with the massive social
upheavals and we're witnessing sort of
uh horrible
climate change that's accelerating front
of our eyes the list goes on right i
just try to i mean i try to at least
with my kids we try to talk about this
from time to time is that they're all
geared up let's we're going back to
school it's going to be normal again
well let's slow down and think about you
know what does normal mean for you and i
what does it mean for people around the
world so i just put that out there yeah
that's a really important point and what
what the new normal will look like
to follow up with that a little bit i'm
curious from the lens from all three of
you what you've seen shift in terms of
campus life since
since the pandemic started and what
you've seen shift for the good and what
you've seen maybe shift for the bad and
ways that we're trying to address that
um we're like maybe we can start with
you if you have any
perspectives there
yes i think a positive shift might be a
greater appreciation for relationships
a greater appreciation for who's in
front of you um i can imagine
students not not wanting to break apart
in their evening conversation or leave
the the group that they're a part of
i can imagine some professors
just
uh really appreciating more deeply being
in the classroom and interacting with
students there's a ease to being in
person in terms of communication in
terms of timing uh that we can take
breaths together
and that we can pause and people can
still follow each other in terms of uh
what's being thought or what's being
communicated and so i think there's to
be a heightened appreciation
for being on site and in the presence of
one another
um and i also think uh
on the challenging side there might be
um
i think dependencies may come out
um i think there may be some unhealthy
uh revelations of behavior or desires
that will allow healing to then come
because of that revelation but i think
that's going to come out um
you know something during the pandemic
uh
many people on campus felt isolated
because even though they were on campus
they weren't necessarily all together
and so you take two isolated people who
want to be together
and they're hanging out maybe more than
they should or there's increases are so
i think there'll be a little uh maybe
over compensation or over correction
in terms of what happened last year
what's been happening over the summer
and the opportunities that will present
themselves uh this coming year um i
think it will be mostly positive and
everything will be an opportunity for
further growth
yeah and again i keep isolating that
words but i think growth is so well said
on that aspect as well because even as
you talked about some of the positives
and some of the areas where there will
be tensions and opportunities for for
learning it seems like that is exactly
what it is that and then to go back to
what sharon said to have grace for some
of those
missteps or challenges along the way and
to make sure there's room
for that because it's a journey that
we're all in together definitely
appreciate you sharing sharing both of
those insights
thank you yeah
and then i know i mean you've also as
we've been talking you've all all of you
and myself included i think we can all
relate to the anxiety component that's
been there that's been there and you
know classically as we talk about
anxiety kind of
that creeps up when there is either
something that's unknown or a perception
of things being unknown and there's a
lot of truth to that in this moment that
we're in right now so also you know in
your interactions with students i'm
curious how you have seen and how you've
walked
with students in terms of their
emotional journeys and their mental
health how have you seen that play out i
would anticipate that it's been a
mixture but would love to hear how that
process has been and then what you take
from those experiences as you head into
this new semester and continue to think
about how you support students in that
way um or maybe we can start with you
this time around
sure thank you um you know two thoughts
come to mind one is uh related to
the point that is that like i students
are so hungry for
community and connection right i mean
literally i open up my email every
morning and i've got a different student
undergrad postdoc like when are we going
to start friday prayers again on campus
like when can we see each other when is
you know the the uh the uh
student life aspect of campus going to
pick up again and the answer is always
um i don't know uh but you know god
willing soon and let's just be patient
right uh and i think that relates to the
the second point about the mental health
is that i think
there aren't any easy answers to this uh
you know to navigate with students but
the thing that i have really been able
to stress in a lot of my one-on-ones
with students and that's in my in my
mind one of the
interesting sort of things that i
discovered with this is that um i'm all
about in-person interaction being
present being present with the other
person but i found myself doing a lot
more one-on-ones right with with
students uh and community members during
this and one of things has come out is
in a strange way we've been able to go
deeper right uh in in some of these
sessions and and with that ones that
have struggled with mental health i've
been able to really spend time and i'm
not uh
a therapist you know i make that very
clear right but to refer them to sources
and i think it's gotten them thinking
right that they have this because
they've slowed down it's almost like
that space has been created in their
life and in their work life to be like
yeah i've kind of put this off and i'm
really struggling and i need this i need
to find someone so can you help me find
someone or what to do or what to read or
who to talk to and that has been sort of
a a a pleasant surprise i may say from
this in my experience
that's great to hear and refreshing as
well and appreciate you being there it
seems like you've helped facilitate that
as well it's a combination of both the
circumstance and the openness to it so
that's really really powerful
i'm sharing what about you from your
perspective as the
lead chaplain in the sense and with the
oversight that you have and the
interactions with students
well i
i have to say i certainly
our schedules really were much more busy
much smaller um we were going at a
slower pace but we were going i felt
like at a fuller
gate with
the amount of students we were seeing
over zoom
and one of the things that became really
clear
early on these were students that i did
not know
that were reaching out because they felt
something was off for them or they were
frightened about how they were feeling
and we were able to get to the heart of
the matter so much more quickly
and i it only occurred to me that that
was happening maybe about halfway into
the year where i'm thinking
wow they didn't even know me and when i
you know asked
a a and sort of open question
they would
would go right in and so what that made
me think about was the distractions in
my office
the things that you know
could get you could buy time before
getting to the heart of the matter
whether it's i have a snow globe
collection and i have goofy little
wind-up toys and i thought to myself
yeah they only had just this you know to
look at
um and so i have thought about
keeping some hours
open over zoom so that people could make
an appointment let's say they just
didn't feel like walking across campus
but they want to talk to somebody and so
i do we've talked about this as a staff
we we are going to hang on to some of
that
um
when you know a couple other colleagues
in our office did anti-racist uh book
groups
and um
they had people uh coming to these book
groups that would never have been able
to do it but they just had to push a
button
and they were there and they could eat
their lunch and then you know push the
button and go back to whatever they were
doing and so we see some sort of
important aha moments in that that i
think you know that the technology that
we are all forced to use
isn't all that bad in some cases
um and so there's that and i think
specifically with some of these
conversations i can remember oh my
goodness the very first student who made
an appointment to see me
when we went into lockdown
and his first question was is this the
end of the world
and in all my years in chaplaincy
no one had asked me that question quite
that way
and
i said it's the end of a world
yeah
and i felt
like gosh i hope i didn't freak him out
by saying that but i also felt it was
important to tell the truth and that's
what i was feeling in that moment and i
think that's true
um that we you know it is it was the end
of a world
um and so our work is what does this
next world need to be so that we are
better in it
and better for it so it you know the
these deep conversations some of them
you know kind of existential and broad
and some of them just
a person is personally terrified to
leave their
house um have been
present in just such a high volume for
for all of us um and i think the last
thing i'll say is just
as the sort of person that has to you
know keep everybody afloat in terms of
the other chaplains
um i just felt so humbled by how we were
when one person was down someone else
stepped in you know and it was just like
we didn't choreograph it that way but i
think all of us all the different
religious and spiritual organizations
just
knew
you know this is hard
and we have to keep going
but we don't have to be
[Music]
perfect so important
[Music]
and i'm encouraged just what the i mean
the theme that's coming up is the
opportunity that's been there in a lot
of ways and it's great to know that
you're keeping both of those in person
and zoom options available to create
more opportunity in some ways as well i
think i think it will lead us to
important insights into how to do how
how other ways to do this work and
honestly
the key has always been
in ministry
not to abandon
so now we're in a situation where we
physically couldn't be together but we
had to think of ways
to help people not feel like they were
abandoned right and that they're
suffering alone
um and so it you know again it's and it
was an imperfect thing but it
did give us some stuff i think that we
have to pay attention to yeah yeah and
creative community and i think even the
way you describe the students i mean i
feel like i have to give them a lot of
uh encouragement and support for just
even taking advantage of that you said
you're hearing from students that you've
never heard from before so taking a step
out of a comfort zone to reach out and
to connect and it sounds like those
conversations are going very deep very
quickly so again that opportunity in
that community and you know encouraging
to hear even the way amongst the
chaplains that you've been able to step
in for each other i think that speaks
well about your community as well and
the ways that you all are supporting
supporting each other in these different
ways so
orlando for you as a uh a pastor of the
black church at yale have you seen some
of these same principles at play are
there other ones that have come up that
we haven't quite touched on as well in
terms of the students emotional journeys
and just support around mental health
yes i'm seeing a lot of overlap
i think for me there's been a dream come
true something that i've desired for
many years and
that is um
ongoing conversation
and just an opportunity for a continuity
of of experience and over this pandemic
it's been nice to be able to
um
have ongoing conversations about
a student's well-being or about what
they're thinking what they're
experiencing what they're dreaming about
or what their concern is versus just you
you speak to somebody once and you don't
hear them hear from them again and so
something that i it's a desire because
it's usually one-on-one and so i'm
trying to think well how do how do we
multiply this but it's the opportunity
to really have
uh someone walk
beside a student
like a shepherd would walk beside sheep
like someone really to take them from
one place to another and be there for
conversation be there for dialogue or
just be there to listen which is mostly
what happens uh me being able to to be
quiet and just hear uh and to ask
questions that will serve the student
and will help bring reflection and
revelation
but also just maybe greater clarity on
where they are or just the assurance
that you're not alone uh even if you may
feel that you're alone in certain ways
i'm also here with you
and then the second thing that has
happened
that i think
uh sharon has really demonstrated so
sharon has this wonderful opportunity to
be a leader of leaders
uh leading the chaplain office chaplains
uh but then also leading the larger
group of religious ministers on campus
and something that sharon has done i
at the end of the semester i realized it
was an opportunity for myself so sharon
helps us to get through the semester
it just helps us to say okay this is
what we're doing this is what needs to
happen and after we get through the
semester uh sharon you help us get
through the year
and you know get through the rest of the
year and um it wasn't until the end of
last semester
that
i realized that one of my goals
or or
one of the opportunities that i had was
just to shepherd the students through
and to not
lose any
and if there is a principle maybe i'll
call it the harriet tubman principle uh
where you're leading uh a group of
people from one place to another place
but you're helping them to make that
journey
and so when i come into this semester
this year one of the things i'm thinking
about is like okay how do i help the
students who have begun this journey to
make it to the next stage
and they don't have to make it perfectly
they don't have to make it necessarily
with all the goals achieved that they've
come into the semester with but how do i
help them to make it and then cause them
to look back and say see how far i've
come
and see that we've come together and
that that's a wonderful opportunity
is a wonderful blessing to be a part of
that process um
and i think that's part of
something that helps with with mental
health is being able to
say
we've done it once
we can do it again
or other people before me have done it
maybe i can do it too
and that's something that i'm looking
forward to
embracing and honoring and cherishing
and rising to the occasion to contribute
to their own journeys from one place to
the beginning place even if it's just uh
the journey from august to december and
then january to may uh and then of
course over the summer because we're
still with them in so many ways
you know that's so good and it
reverberates as you said as they're
learning from their own journeys or
looking to others as well and seeing how
that
that goes forward in a lot of ways and
you know my um i'm trying not to go too
much into neuroscience but in some ways
it thinks about just the way our brains
are designed as well and the ways that
our brains respond to things in our
environment how we're really recreating
those things for us to perceive that i
mean people talk about you know the
memory cells in certain parts of the
brains and taxi drivers they're called
mirror neurons which kind of respond to
you know certain things in the
environment and even just what you're
talking about and
yeah might be getting too far outside
and making this this parallel too strong
but i'm just thinking about the ways
that we can do that in our lives
and learn from that and grow from that
as communities as well um and so yeah
i'm just just encouraged to hear that
approach and for what you what you see
coming forward in this this new semester
as well and i think you're all
highlighting some of the strengths it
seems that you all have been able to
galvanize and that students have also
been using um overall just in terms of
emotional wellness and mental health and
things that they can use going forward
not to make things negative but i'm also
curious if there have been
misperceptions
that you've run into and i bring that up
because i think sometimes that can be
clarifying to speak about in larger
contexts because i know in events that
we've done the past you know after we've
spoken about those things in the public
space people said oh i've been thinking
about these things for years but i've
never had a place to talk about them so
sometimes i think it's helpful for us to
voice those things and to be able to
correct those misperceptions whether
they're intentional or unintentional and
then help us all think about ways to
move forward so i'm just curious if as
you've been interacting with students if
there are certain misconceptions about
either spiritual practices or mental
health that you've had to confront in a
gentle and loving way to help students
move to a better place and if there's
principles we can apply from those
things
going forward so sharon would you be
wanting to uh to start with that
sure um
you know i'm always very candid with
students that i'm not a therapist
and that i will share with them
when they're saying something that is
making me frightened for them
that again i won't
uh
abandon them if i feel like we need we
need to you know we need extra support
here we need to you know go over walk
over to mental health and counseling
i'll stay with them
but i have found what's changed over
time and this really isn't
related to the pandemic i think it's the
time that we're in
is that it's a lot easier to talk about
mental health issues with students from
across many
um religious and spiritual communities
and i can remember a time when it wasn't
so easy
and that there was a lot of shame
involved if there was ever kind of a
conversation about sharing a diagnosis
with a family member or a family member
having a diagnosis and then the
student processing that and not really
knowing what to do with it that has
really changed and changed for the
better
and so now you can have these
conversations with a student let's say
they have a counselor and they're not
comfortable with that person
um you know you can say well if you
didn't like your dentist you would
change their dentist
what's best for your teeth well you want
what's best for your mental health you
know so when when i first do a few
screening questions to find out
is that you know is the the fact that
they don't like the experience does it
have to do with it the fact that they
don't feel better yet
and is that the therapist's fault or is
that part of the process so you know you
kind of have to do a little mining
around that but
um and i'm not sure if this is getting
exactly to your question but i know that
i'm just getting a lot more frank with
students who talk about this and and the
difference between a mental illness
and a time of mental anguish or distress
whether it be from you know bad news or
you know broken heart or something like
that that's the stuff of life and making
the distinguish
you know making a distinction between
the two
so that they can get the best help and
also understand that they can survive it
yeah i think that's really helpful i
mean even as someone who's not a mental
health professional to help the students
identify that as well because that's
something that students and all of us
can struggle with at times you know when
there is that mental anguish or
something that happens in the moment and
really trying to distinguish between
those because i think and this has come
up in other episodes before there has
been healthier language
around mental health but sometimes i
think it does get confusing
um so even we had a victoria garrett
who's a former d1 athlete trying to
really encourage people when they say
that they're feeling depressed but then
also trying to think about well are they
really depressed or is this something in
the moment and is it something to have
always need to have the tools to walk
through those versus trying to pull in
and get extra help so the fact that the
students are allowing you to be frank in
those conversations i think it's really
healthy in a lot of ways and very
encouraging
yeah i think it is and i think we've
seen this also from the olympic athletes
who are naming
what they're going through and
normalizing that
and you know
naming their needs and normalizing the
language in such a way that i think you
know young people will look at that and
go oh
that isn't quite what i thought it was
you know and and they're okay and other
things happened and that's okay too
um i think all of that is to the good
yeah definitely and as you mentioned
having the openness to say okay you can
walk them down to uh mental health and
counseling and there's there's not shame
that should be associated with that it's
just part of the process and you should
be we should all be thinking about
getting the help that we need for
whatever we might be going through any
specific point in time whether it's just
the anguish of a situation or something
that's much more all-consuming so that's
encouraging for me to hear as well
yeah definitely
omar anything that you've you've run
into or noticed with with the students
that you've been working with
sure uh uh and thank you sharon for for
setting that up uh uh in fact that one
of the things that i want to talk about
which is related to that is there was a
new study that was just published in
jama psychiatry last week that got a lot
of press npr did a story on it and it
got national press it was out of
stanford and really quickly the summary
of it and it was very relevant to this
is that you know that they found that
the american muslim community is twice
as likely to have attempted suicide as
compared to other religious communities
and then it was a fascinating study an
article that delved into the reasons
they said there's really two factors
right one is religious discrimination
the the the toxic corrosive effects of
islamophobia and of xenophobia on these
communities and the second is community
stigma and that's where i want to
connect with what sharon was saying is
that you know
all of our communities in their
respective ways have had stigmas against
mental health and talking frankly about
these conversations and i think one
thing has happened now is that our
communities at least my community in
particular i'll just talk about this is
finally the door is opening right where
you know we are reaching uh you know uh
crisis levels of this the corrosive
effects of this stigma and so we need to
start talking about this and i really
want to applaud the people who
participate in this i know the the
director that ran the study at stanford
wonderful female scholar um dr rania wad
and just you know really that from our
community and then looking outward is is
pulling the curtain back on these
stigmas um
uh because it's something that our
students right and connect to the second
thing i want to say is that you know for
the longest time uh our students uh
haven't wanted to talk about these
things but maybe just something with the
pandemic is it opened up conversation
doors right and one of the things uh and
to sharon's point about just being frank
i really love the way we frame that is i
want to say this is that you know we
understand yale is a high octane place
the type of people that come to yale the
type of people that that excel at yale
it's all about excellence it's a lot
being the best from the faculty to the
staff to the students to the athletes
and on and so it becomes actually i
think very problematic in that that
coupled with this like idea of the grind
and hustle culture right is that like
what's what am i doing on my tick tock
and my ig you know how is it part of my
brand and furthering my place in the
world and i think our students are
really susceptible to that and some of
the frank conversation i had my students
is like
that's not all real like we all need to
learn to dial it down and to be real
there's a performativeness that is
almost fetishized i think amongst our
society now and especially at these high
pressure you know cookers like yale and
that i think uh one of the it's a
negative but it's a breakthrough that i
think i had with some students or the
students have themselves i should say is
that they're just like
yeah that's not sustainable that wasn't
that's not gonna be sustainable through
the pandemic and i don't know if it's
gonna be sustainable afterward so
you know if they're able
you know from that negative experience
to walk in to say that i need to dial it
down
hey that's a win right um so yeah that's
something i put out there oh that's
great that's great and something that i
think is so applicable even the broader
sense and
you know as you're as you're talking
about i'm thinking like if that
framework can perpetuate how powerful
that can be to really just shift
things across across culture and i'm
encouraged to hear that you've had those
conversations in a lot of ways and the
openness openness is definitely
important um and even as i mean you
mentioned the first the first challenge
though you know with all the
islamophobia and xenophobia that still
obviously still has to be addressed but
um
encouraged that the conversation is
happening and you know those other
pieces are much bigger conversations
than
then we're having here but you know just
it'd be great to see you know on both
sides if we can really do that across
the board so but
again just i feel like i'm repeating
myself but i'm grateful for just the way
that you all are engaging with the
students and just all this coming out of
that already which i think is really
powerful and impactful or that i do
anything you wanted to add in your uh
your interactions with your students
your sphere of influence as well
yes i think one
um
kind of
misunderstanding or even missed
opportunity
is in recognizing the overlap between
community care and health and individual
care and health as it relates to mental
health and students in my experience are
more open to speaking about what's
happening for them individually and
requesting things individually but
students won't necessarily talk with
each other
as much as i think they could benefit if
there was more of a community of support
in a community of care and one of my
challenges is saying okay how can i
support what's happening at the
individual level
and in an appropriate way and in a way
that can be healing
to allow the community aspect to come
together so that's something that i'm
working on so i think this
there seems to be not a stigma with
being transparent one on one but perhaps
uh still a stigma with being transparent
and more of a group setting
so that's one thing that that i'm
experiencing and thinking about and the
other piece is when students do want
help they're asking me to help them to
find
specialists who look like them and have
their faith background
or that even as they're going through
a treatment process or care process uh
they are not
um
directed away from their values
and so that has uh presented me with an
opportunity to try to see okay who are
individuals who may relate with students
and do some betting
in a way uh and i found that is is not
easy
it is not easy like i don't have a huge
large pool to choose from
um what does help
is the opportunity of virtual support
so maybe there's a larger network than
just who was in let's say new haven or
connecticut
but
might be able to connect students with
professionals who are in their own
hometown or home country and to be able
to do that um
so i think those are two areas being
more of a community
support and having mental health to be a
community process and focus
and then also helping students to
be okay with who i walk them to in terms
of
getting more professional help and those
are two areas that i need to grow in
that i'm trying to train in right now so
that i'm better equipped and i have more
of a network
of professionals around me as we dive
into this for this particular year and
beyond yeah yeah that's really important
i'm glad you brought that to the
forefront as well you know something
that the field has been grappling with
for a while in a lot of ways just making
sure that people are you know the phrase
people used to have cultural competency
in terms of what background they have
and even the faith traditions i mean i
think the mental health field has moved
forward in a lot of ways i think and
sharon you mentioned this before even
within the mental health field i think
in the past there was a tendency to be
dismissive
about people's cultural experiences and
to be dismissive about the faith
journeys whereas now there is more of a
push to say no we really need to think
about people as whole people and not
pretend that those things aren't part of
people's lives and not pretend that even
despite all the research and the
evidence so end up being members of
communities and faith communities in
general you know can have both positive
and negative effects on people's mental
health depending on how that's
approached
but you can't just dismiss the whole
thing
and remove that and you know it's people
of faith here who uh believe in the
power of god to work through these
things that needs to be integral as well
but to your point orlando it's still
difficult for people to get connected
with the resources because the resources
aren't what they need to be so
kudos to you for doing that homework but
in some ways it also reflects on the
system that you have to do that homework
in the first place and it's not readily
available that's something we're still
definitely moving forward um with and
just you know and just to say you know
if your students want access to
resources they can definitely reach out
to me and i can put them in touch um
with folks some several of the guests
who have come on this podcast have
focused on that in particular and so i
think it's an ongoing
and important conversation again just
appreciate
your transparency and sharing that
because it's really really important and
critical and again i keep harping back
to this but you all are on the front
lines in so many ways and really
encouraging and empowering the students
in those conversations and normalizing
it as well i know we used normalizing in
different ways we can't get back to
normal that we had before but we can
continue to normalize these
conversations and it sounds like you all
are doing that um in so many ways
the time always goes fast on this on
this podcast but i did want to wrap up
just by talking about the vision that
you all have for the year going forward
and vision in the sense of hopes and
dreams maybe not in the sense of
specific strategies because we've
already made sure that that's not
acknowledged that's not the case here um
but yeah just your vision for
yourselves and and for the students as
they're coming back and not to throw too
many questions in at once but as we've
been talking i've also been thinking
about all three of you and just your own
emotional wellness as you are carrying
and walking through with the students
and that can be a load and a burden
sometimes not that it's meant to be a
burden but just you know hoping that you
all have the space for your own
self-care as well and it sounds like you
have that in community but um just
curious you know as you talk about
vision if there's space for you to even
talk about how you envision that for
yourself as well so
that was a very loaded and very compound
question so i i feel bad calling on
anyone to go first but
i'm going to anyway uh omar would you be
sure we wanted to jump in
um no i really appreciate the question
the questions in that and so what i
would say is two things one is that um
you know uh just the return to community
and to just be honest about what that's
going to look like that we're gonna
phase it in uh but the goal is
ultimately god willing to move to uh
more connected community um i think that
that we can be authentic and honest with
our community with our students right
with our communities not just students
um because that way we manage
expectations uh so my vision is is that
we're gonna emerge from this uh wisened
and and in many ways uh uh you know with
a deeper appreciation for the things
that we missed uh that we've missed out
on that we've lost um uh in one sense
and then in terms of the other thing
that i would say
is
um
you know
i think that uh you know there's a
saying right every chapel needs a
chaplain and so i am so deeply grateful
for for sharon and orlando uh and
yourself and you know just friends and
colleagues that that are in these spaces
that do this work that at least for me
help me process it because i am you know
an obsessive reader of news uh
unfortunately i'm a news junkie and if
and the world is a very uh difficult uh
in many ways heartbreaking place and and
you know if we get tunnel vision it gets
sucked into that it is so disheartening
so i think the ability to be able to
process it with with friends and loved
ones
and to just really talk it through um
that to me is just like i've been a
saving grace um and i think helps us
keep all our sanity and and our sort of
mental health and spiritual health so
i'm great agreed well appreciate you
talking that through with us today too
because it's been it's been encouraging
and and in some ways eye-opening for me
as well just to hear again just the
pieces that you've all been walking
through with your students
orlando what about you
yes i'm saying about two things one
values
and gifts
so in terms of values what what are our
community values that we can lean
into at this time and what are our
individual values um that i can help
encourage students to lean in to at this
time so even if it's not
even if a strategy is not quite clear or
program is not quite clear
we can have
a matrix
upon which or through which we make
decisions and that matrix can be our
collective and individual values
now the challenge is
uh
whichever with every new semester with
every new school year the population
of students changes and with that there
may become
and values or maybe not but i think i'm
still gonna have to go through the
process
of saying okay well what are our values
and how can we lean into them one so
that we are sure where we stand
but also so that we can let other people
know where we stand and be more of an
inviting community
and then that will allow us uh
especially on my end to
have values-based collaboration
so for for orlando to do what orlando
can do well and then for me to broaden
the network of who our members and
students can uh reach out to and be in
community with uh so that community you
know one blessing of the pandemic is
that our identity is not tied to a place
it's not tied to a physical location
it's not tied to an address it's not
even tied to a time zone so how can we
think uh more broadly and more
inclusively about who we are and who we
can be in relationship to one another
and uh if we can
start to identify
um
and choose what values we want i think
that will help with collaboration and
deepening community
and then the other piece in terms of
gifts
uh
i think there's healing in the body and
i think that everything
um
everything we need is in the house and i
think about god's house but i think
there are enough gifts
i think that there are enough strengths
in who we are collectively
that
when any one of us leans into those
strengths but at the same time we really
can
bring a lot of hope bring a lot of
healing bring a lot of positive
transformation to everyone with whom we
are connected
i know one of my gifts is exhortation
and
you know exhortation is a time for now
or now is the time for exaltation so i'm
trying to say okay how can i lean into
who i am and for people who have other
strengths how can i encourage them to
lean in to those strengths and bk is a
student-run church
and students um
as their young adults beginning they
don't always recognize
uh what their strengths are what their
gifts are and what the gem is that they
bring
to their families or those around them
um and some who do recognize they don't
believe it
and a question i have is orlando okay
how can i help uh raise for them the
opportunity to see that not only are
they are part of a larger community but
they are a valuable part of a larger
community and not based on how they
perform but based on who they are at
their core and what they value and what
they see
and i think that's a challenge that i
want to lean into
as we go into this year to
celebrate
gifts of what people bring to the table
and also to lift up values to see if we
can be more collaborative and expand our
definition of community
that's so good
so many important pieces there i mean
just the value component as well and the
strengths that students can bring to
encourage one another in some ways i'm
speculating here but i have a sense that
that's something that you all are doing
in your role in the chaplain's office as
well even the way you talked about
leaning on one another people stepping
in the people have a sense of their
values and their strengths and their
gems and are able to use those to
encourage the whole body
within the chaplain's organization so to
see that amongst your students as well
goes such a long way and even from i'm
thinking just in terms of a mental
health perspective you know some of the
mental health interventions they're
really focused on perspective
you know what is actually happening in
the world versus how do i perceive that
and really shifting that to make sure
that perceptions match the reality and
so if the students are getting a sense
of their true value and having that
perception how powerful that can be to
moving forward not that it solves
everything but having that appropriate
and fixed perspective in the same way
that we can do that um through reading
holy scriptures and things like that to
reshape our perspective what does god
say about us and how do we use that to
then interact with the world and think
about ourselves so
yeah just just encouraged by the framing
that you've put there and for all that
you all are doing
sharon to give you the last word to wrap
all this together with these great
comments from omar and orlando well i'm
humbled by my beloved preaching brothers
so i can i won't be i won't be anywhere
near as eloquent but
i will honestly say my vision is blurry
for the future but i am fueled by grace
i have an abiding faith that that is
present and um
and i hope to embody it
in forms of compassion and kindness and
um
you know how to sustain that for
ourselves so that we can continue to to
do this work
really has to do with um
you know in many ways knowing your
limits knowing that you
are called to be present but you aren't
called to fix
and so to not look away
to
lead with kindness and compassion
and
know that the rest uh is really out of
our hands
um but i do you know i feel grateful for
my colleagues i feel grateful for my
family
um
and i know that you know
the
the impact of this work is something we
won't see
and that i came to terms with that years
ago you know and um and there's a
lightness to that that i think is is
healthy to keep in mind especially at a
place like yale where there's lots of
talk about legacy and you know impact
and all these things
i i can't do the work with that in mind
i i do the work for the for the present
and um and hope that those seeds lead to
a better world
such a good wisdom
agreed agreed
well thank you to all of you for this
rich conversation very edifying a lot of
ways you know even as we're walking
through these challenging times even
with the uncertainties to know just the
power of community and the power of
knowing our value and knowing our worth
and having others who are walking
through that with us i think ghost goes
so far and will be important for all of
us across the country as we're heading
back into this
this new semester with so many different
different aspects of what we haven't
experienced before so again grateful to
the work that you all are doing grateful
for your willingness to share this with
our audience i know it's going to be
something that will be enriching and a
blessing to them as well and thank you
again for taking time out of your
schedules even as you're getting close
to this semester started to come here
and have this conversation i'm deeply
appreciative
thank you thank you thank you so much
nee
thank you
[Music]